foreign
JC is with us in Fort Worth Hey JC
what's up
Happy Thanksgiving to you how can we
help
well I'm calling today because I'm
the short story is that since August
we've had
some major home repairs totaling about
um forty thousand dollars that are going
to send us back into Consumer Debt
because we don't have that kind of cash
in the bank
so I guess my question is at what point
do we cut our losses and say goodbye to
this house
okay what kind of home repairs pop up so
suddenly and unexpectedly
right so
[Music]
um
we had to get our HVAC replaced in
August
um when we bought the house it was only
two years old which we thought you know
was a dream what did you pay for that
so the HVAC was about 15. we got the
lowest Seer that we could so you paid
for that that's done
um no we had to finance that
so you had no money when you moved in
the house
well so we moved into the house in 2019
um and you had no money
when you're when your HVAC went out
so we have we have about 13 000 in the
bank and so we could pay for most of it
yes but you didn't
no we did not okay so what is it on you
want me to so you're trying to decide
whether to keep the house what was the
other thing that went wrong yeah so the
foundation
um
basically with the drought that we had
in Texas this summer the house was
falling apart at the seams major cracks
um so we we actually had gotten a quote
for the foundation a couple years ago
and it was only 4 000 at the time and
then we ended up waiting on it and it
ended up being a lot more so that was 95
and then to validate what was 95 you've
already done it
yeah so you've already financed that too
yes Oh I thought you told me you were
going had to do these repairs and then
you were going to be in debt so you've
already made all these decisions
well there's one more decision that
and so to validate the warranty for the
the lifetime the um the lifetime
warranty on the foundation we need to
pass a plumbing test and we failed that
and the minimum repairs for that are
thirteen thousand but they're not
entirely sure that that's going to fix
it they the same people that did the
foundation did the plumbing repair
no no it was a different company are
they friends
yes they are and I've been working on
getting
um yes they can trench up your entire
yard for less than that that's absolute
BS okay I'd call another company to come
out and start I'm calling BS I'm calling
a lawyer you're going to certify this
dead gum Foundation that you put in for
ten thousand dollars today
period
this idea that I have to get Plumbing
done from your friend before I get your
warranty on work you did BS I'm about to
bust somebody in the chops
okay
I don't think you're gonna do it are you
because you're convinced that you're
convinced the whole damn thing's falling
down
yeah I am yeah right and so yeah if you
want to sell it because you don't like
you're mad at the house
very true yes yeah so what's this piece
of garbage worth
it's probably worth about well it's
maybe 300 000. it might be a little we
might have to you know take a little bit
less on it now with what do you owe on
it I'm slowing down about 180. okay
all right uh I think you're going to
sell your house because I think you hate
your house
but I also think you've got to figure
out a way to start living your life
without drama to drama to debt to debt
yeah it's not going because you're
always gonna have drama around the house
and you're gonna have to you have to
finish you're going to finish borrowing
money on it and you're gonna have to
think differently about the process but
I I don't know about your husband but I
do know about his wife she's tired of
this house she's ready to move
I think my husband is more tired than I
am actually
I mean but now you're gonna get
everything all fixed I'm gonna I'm not
doing the plumbing Bozo that did the
repair on the uh foundation's about to
issue me a warranty or I'm about to come
after him for doing work that he can't
warranty
this is a problem this is a problem and
I smell a red and it stinks
so could be wrong not calling him a
crook just saying sure does look like
one
and so uh that's what I'm doing and then
I'm gonna put the house on the market
and sell the crap out of it and move and
this time by something that and listen
and then and then stop this garbage stop
all this justification and we're stuck
and it's the only thing
we're trapped and all this stuff happens
to us you're going to have to happen to
it right and it's time that you guys get
control of this stuff and if you buy a
house in the DFW areas you're gonna have
Foundation challenges you're going to
have air conditioning I mean that just
just got to make peace with that if
you're gonna be a homeowner in some of
those areas yeah yeah which means you
can't like you mentioned you can't buy a
house you don't have any money and you
also get a good home inspection before
you buy the house right yeah and
um you should know with a good home
inspection if you have more than two
years of life left in the HVAC yes um
you gotta you got a 12 year old HVAC
it's come it's common shortly get ready
you know I mean it's working perfect now
yeah yeah it won't be for long it's
coming at you I mean you know you got a
four-year-old HVAC you should get more
than two more years out of it hello so
um I mean this is you know it's basic
stuff these things have a life
and a lifespan and the lifespan is only
so long you said it Dave
um and it reminds me
uh
JC you're gonna sell this house you're
gonna buy a new house
and if you don't quickly and
dramatically deal with the drama in your
home
with how you'll handle money how you'll
handle each other how you handle
um YOLO versus we're going to say slow
down and save up for Stuff
you're going to realize in short order
they're going to buy a new house and you
and your husband went with you
and they are going to show up at that
new house there's going to be more we
need this we got to buy this and we got
to have this and this is going to break
and the whole cycle starts over again
yeah
part of me thinks the spiritual exercise
would be to sit there for a couple three
months six months and make peace with
your relationship with your husband and
y'all make peace with decision making
and then get into something else then
you're not going to do that but man
there's something about running from
mess to mess to mess you said it Dave
you got to deal with the drama or it's
just gonna follow you
it's gonna follow you follow you follow
you follow you this is Thanksgiving it's
probably not a bad idea to sell your
house in the spring rather than at
Christmas
some you know in terms of Market timing
or whatever
um so it might be it's okay yeah go
ahead and bust on the foundation guy get
that certified and then just sit there
enjoy the new property get it get you
know start you know spend a month or two
clean it up get ready to sell start
talking about putting it on the market
in March and you put it in the meantime
in the meantime get your head around
okay we're gonna control these
controllables these variables coming at
us are not going to control us
and when you live from stress to stress
to crisis to crisis debt to debt
um it's a cycle that you have to
intellectually and an act of your will
break that cycle and it's not easy to do
um I was the same way I mean
uh we're at our house Ramses we are
built-in drama queens oh I mean we can
add drama to anything so it's one of my
spiritual gifts man
so Ian Crone created a a tenth Enneagram
for me just for you just drama queen
number 10 on anything that's right and
so yeah that's it and uh you know so I
understand where you're doing but one of
the things I had to do is I had to break
myself from feeling like these
circumstances were controlling me
these things coming at me were
controlling me and there's that sense of
power of backing up three steps and go
yeah maybe not
maybe not maybe we're not using your
buddy to fix the plumbing